the Philadelphia Inquirer says GoFundMe  plans to fully reimburse a homeless man  who claims a couple withheld hundreds of  thousands of dollars from him police  raided the home of Kate McClure and mark  D'Amico yesterday  Johnny Bobbitt is suing the New Jersey  couple who raised $400,000 in a highly  publicized campaign on his behalf  the trio met last year after Bobbitt  spent his last $20 bill to fill  McClure's tank when she ran out of gas  the couple had no comment in that video  we just saw John they were taking away  the couple's brand-new BMW that they  said that they didn't use any of the  GoFundMe money for but it's just the  story has taken such a sad turn yes  literally stories the difference between  the uplifting feeling you had at the  beginning and where we are now is quite  basically stayed up here you know